you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game let's play d5 see what Y
throws at us and a head for a slob no
increment okay we could get a pretty
sharp line soon Bishop g5 and it will be
sharp no I was gonna take okay let's
just get the night here right away I
want to be prepared to take out a knight
if he arrives here also this could still
turn sharp
let's take right away and play b5 see
where the bishop goes expecting d3 to
have a 94 move and now I think it's
either Bishop d7 or a six
I'm gonna go with Bishop d7 first yeah I
think this is right I think both moves
are are fine I'll be looking for a six
and a quick c5 so let's see what white
does most critical line I imagine is e4
I'll be playing c5 no that's different
huh
well let's not panic I think on h6
there's some sacrifices here with bishop
here let's get in c5 right away I don't
think I'm missing anything with the
Queen coming out I have these 3 squares
covered and a question I have is how
exactly to recapture should white take
on c5 probably with the knight I mean I
could develop a new piece but taking
like this seems pretty good so I'm
looking at rook c8 uh yeah probably rook
c8 he knows his place yeah
this is gonna be an open file so let's
get there still holding off on the
bishop development Knight takes I'll be
taking with the knight okay now let's
just get a move in I could only hold off
on the bishop move for so long not sure
why that move was played if I really
want to kick the night I could still do
that it's a very weakening move to this
diagonal let's get right on it excuse me
we're even on time it's looking to put
pressure on the weaknesses here III I'm
opposite there King so there's some pins
going on probably take right now now I
don't need to
soon rook F to d8 have very good
development and this bishop is gonna
have a tough time I think rook FD 8
there's a lot of pressure on the flight
position that night still isn't
bothering me let's just get here have
this defended clean here who
there and I feel like I should open
things up right now mmm yeah let's take
once I feel like I could jump in with
Knight c5 soon
let's see should give that night a kick
first hmm
let me give him a boot I wouldn't mind
seeing some exchanges here so I could
strike at D for a little bit easier and
how about hmm feels like there should be
a way to take advantage of this pawn
here should I give up my light-square
bishop hmm I'm not sure I want some I
want some exchanges I think let's get
this night here I could defend against
uh some battery against h7 with Knight
f6 or Knight f8 all right now my rook
has some clear sight I like this also
I'm pointing at g2 indirectly f3 Queen
c6 or Queen b7 my Knights kind of stupid
on e7 d7 I wouldn't mind a light square
bishop exchange I could have things turn
a bit positional let's go here first I'm
kind of giving up on putting pressure on
d4 I want a high up this Square and also
Bishop e3 threatening on g2 right now
wow that is so cool
echoing okay let's just play it simple
have a very vulnerable King I'm going to
have a fantastic square for either my
queen or knight on d5 and I'm looking to
now enter next currently on the bishop
hmm okay let's not burn too much time
let's just make a quick move wanna play
a little faster here it's a good
position and how about we improve the
night now yeah I might even anchor them
in there with f5 I weakened this square
but I could take out this Knight f5
Bishop f6 I wouldn't be hmm and then see
that move there opposite my queen huh
okay that's a bit of a bug I must say
let's go here I guess Knight to d6 to
defend f7
rook c5 is a bit a bit of a pain I think
I just have to move my queen it's not
fun to run it like this but yeah I think
I could get away with this let's go
clean here
Bishop move I don't think there's a
great discovery looking for a queen
exchange I want to release the pressure
on f7 no fancy Knight move there might
be something like knight c6 here I have
a minute left hitting everything oh okay
didn't see that one coming I guess I
want to take the rook and how they do
have a past pawns out there definitely
lost the thread here with that one
little threat against f7 hmm not cool
they have a past pun there are checks on
a8 yeah I have to look for some Queen
activity Wow
my rooks trapped oh brother
oh wow
my rooks trapped I don't have anything I
guess on Bishop d4 I have to play here
though and there's even that wow did I
lose the threat on this one
I should just resign you know wow I had
control over those light squares in the
one threat against f7 really rattled me
huh should have never happened like that
man that I just saw it as like a
completely dominant positional position
let me flip the board here and that one
little threat against f7 the opening was
fine I'm certain of this and to see f3
oh man this is a tough one the stomach
age six
that can't be so bad Knight f6 hmm I
shouldn't have moved my knight right
here this is the start of things going
wrong here I have to do something
different in this position 94 gives
white a take advantage of the weakness I
leave behind with my last move hmm
God do something different here maybe
Bishop to d6 get rid of their Knight and
I'm kind of looking for a good night
versus bad Bishop position but I
completely overlooked I I didn't even
see this attack against f7 and it really
it really stung cuz now if I'm doing
this pawn takes and my knight has to
leave defense of this I guess I could
try this but I'm pliant I'm dropping h6
hmm I should have budged with my knight
94 I kind of just saw in the game as hey
it's a night improvement I have some
security here with my queen but and just
give up the h5 square I'm sure it's and
it's still defendable but it's tricky I
mean I shouldn't be allowing any type of
activity for white now that should just
never happened in this kind of position
where I have very good control over the
light squares and the correct kind of
harmony between my structure and my
bishop he's not such a great piece they
have a vulnerable King in long term this
there should be something I could it
should be something I could be
exploiting but mmm Queen h5 one move
and then it's uh crumbles early they're
wise to keep the Queens on and I'm
probably unwise to take the rook and
give them a passed pawn I was scared I
was a bit too fearful just the night
moving right here with an attack against
my queen what I could be doing here is
just making a knight move I shouldn't
have been so quick to give them this
past see pawn so I I definitely panicked
here I just saw it as all the Knights
ready to move attack my queen but hang
on I could go here and I have this
attack and at least I'm not giving white
that passed pawn which was a killer in a
way he it feels like the the pawn is a
connected pass pawn with the bishop here
I extend the scope of the bishop I make
the bishop relevant by capturing the
rook that's one way to view it but yeah
I definitely panicked around this point
taking the rook out of fear of the
knight move with an attack against my
queen probably Knight c4 and on g4 this
also paves the way for the Queen to go
here should my queen be hit with g4
hmmmm maybe maybe this isn't good either
come to think of it Knight here now I
could do that yeah I could take like
this hmm
yeah interesting I think I would
definitely revisit this opening for sure
I'm pretty sure I equalized we'll have a
quick look at it with the computer not
the most testing line here I haven't
haven't seen this kind of maneuver
Knight g5 into e4 because I'm getting
the Krait correct break in I get in c5
and that Bishop isn't really playing f3
was a bit surprising weakening the diag
and all that hmm maybe even around here
I could be taking advantage of this this
is a move I didn't voice it during the
game on takes I get to give a
first save my queen and then get theirs
but they didn't have to take if I played
Knight here and I don't know where what
his what his next move would be maybe
even h6 and after the Knight move I
could go in here looking for the e4
square although Queen here and where
exactly is he going
can't he doesn't really have a good
forward move from here okay well let's
have a quick look at it with the
computer and see where we can make some
improvements ok stockfish let's see what
we can learn from you
another tough one to stomach this is the
mirin variation so far so good
efore is the top move it already likes
black
yeah.he fours the move here within c5
and as we're seeing d5 very critical
continuation okay they didn't go with
that Knight g5 c5 and Roxy a it's fine
Bishop e7 is fine Queen b6 castles yeah
it's an advantage I mean material
balance but it's definitely a superior
position here for black there I have all
my pieces flying to the Queen and Bishop
aren't doing anything I captured it's
okay with that ye5 who tending towards
+2 hmm how can I have maybe had that
move register better with me
he's powerless he's pinned hmm he 5
takes I am helping out there rook and
Bishop but this is pretty serious this
was a night that you know before I
started looking at it with the computer
I was saying you know I could be doing a
move like this and if he's taken I'm
doing this and then I was pointing out
well white of course doesn't have to
take the night this was you know if I
just look back to this point and ask of
myself
which one of my pieces is the worst one
it's this guy here so II five is helping
out my worst piece he may soon turn into
my best piece on takes takes a knight on
c4 would be a fantastic piece and what
are they doing about d4 Bishop e3
there's 90 to g4 hmm I could just see
this crumbling very fast for white with
the correct strike 'if I've hmm that's
not so difficult to see now that you
look at it after the game mmm
taking advantage of that pin okay well I
have it a bit more of a positional
mentality during the game but okay noted
'if I've was available Knight f3 Bishop
takes is suggested I think I wanted to
do that but not sure what kept me from
yeah well I I just seen my bishop as a
really good piece so and just focused on
controlling the light squares 85v sevens
fine getting a light square bishop
exchange is fine clean d5 is okay and
now I'm going in the wrong direction
with this the evaluation doesn't change
so much
with that move so what could I be doing
different on this Queen h5 move wants to
play g6 giving up my H pawn not really a
fan of that Bishop f6
this isn't you know this wouldn't be a
tough choice to even to even give up a
pond like this I'd be wanting to I'd
want to do something different than 94
v-form is a move just keeping my knight
right here um a way I could have looked
at it is white wants to develop their
queen and as soon as I move my knight I
give them up I give up a square for the
Queen it doesn't get any more active
than that does it the Queen improving by
four ranks and to throwing a punch this
is my only sensitive point and I allowed
it to be attacked hmm so I could go it's
B for maintaining my queen position
keeping the tension between the rooks
looking to open up some stuff on the
Queen side takes Bishop takes rook e2
and by this time I mean there's maybe I
jump in 94 a little bit later there
isn't the Queen coming over here mm-hmm
I really felt like I had such good
control I know I did but
queen h5 as soon as i went on the
defensive here as soon as i had to come
up with some defensive moves i've c5
queen b7 mm-hmm
still all right I mean I'm losing my
advantage here okay
Queen b7 want to go with clean f5 is now
no good so this is really where it turns
Queen f3 is a good reply I would get
everything I wanted if they exchanged
Queens just more simplification and
tending more towards a strong night
versus a bad Bishop situation so I
shouldn't have played queen of five
mm-hmm I could see many players wanting
to do this though because I want to
release the pressure against f7 huh it's
just not working out though Queen b7
instead with a possible idea to move the
bishop take the knight also have the
Queen there to defend f7 I have a very
strong night this is still - still fine
structure for me but yeah
Queen f5 and now it's going way downhill
and this is a losing move
taking the rook I think I was pointing
out Knight c4 here it's not really a fan
of that
takes
in the 93 getting getting some material
to minor pieces for the rook than
in-betweener
hmm that's interesting after I take the
rook I guess it's just gone plus three
now for white and a really cool move
here that just kills everything if I
play rook a7 there's c6 this Queen is
guarding everything their King is
perfect a more long-term he's he's
weakened but I'm definitely not in a
position to attack the white king here I
got my own worries past pawn bishop
sprung to life now yeah this one's gone
mmm that's a tough one I had a nice grip
but let it slip here with allowing some
activity against f7 and they I really
panicked by capturing the rook here and
just giving white that passed pawn that
was unnecessary okay well as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below and I hope
you got something out of it that's all
for now take care bye
you